was there any ways that it actually felt
like a sister relationship one hundred
percent in good and bad ways yeah yeah
emma kenny is getting candid about her
former shameless on-screen big sister
emmy rossum
tell me you didn't go fiona on him and
tell him what he's supposed to do going
fiona is not a thing trust me it's a
thing during a conversation with alex
cooper on spotify's call her daddy
podcast the 22 year old actress reveals
how she felt after emmy exited the show
i was of course happy the show was
continuing because you know we have a
great time doing it and right i i love
my i love my shameless family and um
yeah no it was it was it was weird at
first for sure but it also the set
became a little bit more of a positive
place i'm not gonna lie that's great i
would i remember pre her leaving i'd go
to set some days and i'd be very anxious
about having a scene with her because
wow because she had a bad day she made
it a bad day for everybody e.t has
reached out to the network showtime and
emmy for comment though shameless came
to an end in april 2021 emmy left the
series back in 2019 after playing fiona
gallagher for nine seasons
so what are your plans
uh well i'm gonna go to that uh allen on
meeting no not today for the future i
i don't know i haven't really thought
about it we were both so young
i was obviously a lot younger there were
times where she would try to be a good
influence and then there were times
where she would be blatantly giving me
not the best advice and maybe she was
struggling with her own inner problems
and
taking it out on other people we all
handle situations differently but
growing up i definitely
took note from not just her in
particular but people of things i want
to carry on in my life and things i do
not want to carry on in my life but that
wasn't the only problem emma says she
experienced during her time on the show
the connors star who has a 13-year age
gap with emmy also felt like they were
pitted against each other i felt that
dynamic for sure and i never understood
it because i was nine and she was like
over 10 years older than me so i'm like
why is there a weird competition here
when i'm not trying to compete right i
don't know if it was other people on set
creating that or if it was her creating
it yeah but i know i wasn't creating it
and despite any difficult moments at the
time of emmy's departure in 2019 emma
shared with et some positive words about
their relationship how sad are you to
see emmy leave
i mean i love emmy she's her and i i've
grown up with her as her as a big sister
figure
but um yeah no it's not going to be the
end of my relationship with her or any
of the cast on the podcast though emma
reveals she hasn't spoken to emmy in
years she says there's no bad blood i
have a lot of love for her and i i hope
that she finds her happiness and i heard
she had a baby and that's beautiful and
i'm sure she's going to be a lovely
mother
[Music]